buenas tardes como lo menciona serán
elegidos los dos finalistas de los que
saldrá el nuevo o la nueva primera
ministra británica y tres candidatos
todavía en esta carrera reach y zoom a
que el ex ministro de finanzas de boris
johnson list tras la actual secretaria
de exteriores y penn de mordente que
nada también desempeñado un cargo
importante en el gobierno en el
ministerio de comercio y fue la primera
ministra de defensa mujer por los
resultados de la última semana rich es
una que pareciera que es el gran
favorito dentro de los diputados
conservadores mientras que penny morgan
es la favorita por las encuestas que se
han conocido de las bases tories quienes
finalmente son quienes eligen al nuevo
primer ministro y por supuesto ahora hay
nerviosismo negociaciones de último
minuto estos tres candidatos están
tratando de asegurarse de los máximos
votos para pasar a la siguiente etapa la
gran pregunta hasta ahora es para quien
irán los votos de que me va de noche que
fue la última eliminada están tratando
de hacer negociaciones de último minuto
para que éstos vayan
tras que es considerada la candidata de
la derecha dentro del partido
conservador ya se abrieron las urnas en
la sala del comité 1922 del parlamento
británico y se espera que los resultados
se den a conocer rápidamente en las
próximas horas así en louis además hoy
es la última sesión de controles de
boris johnson frente al legislativo como
jefe de gobierno que ha trascendido
sobre esta ronda de preguntas luisa
pero johnson se despidió del parlamento
británico en su condición de primer
ministro la gran pregunta ahora es si va
a continuar como diputado porque él es
en esencia un congresista lo ha hecho
muy a su manera ha dicho en español
hasta la vista baby y curiosamente es
que como no ha como ha sucedido en
anteriores oportunidades el johnson no
fue ovacionado de pie por toda la cámara
de los comunes solamente por su partido
el partido conservador eso nos muestra
el malestar de boris johnson que recibió
hoy nuevas acusaciones de mentiroso por
todo el escándalo del partido gates y
los otros que de los que fue
protagonista pero hubo tiempo para
johnson para sacar pecho por los que
consideran sus logros el break city y la
vacunación contra el kobe 19 johnson
estará en el cargo hasta el próximo 6 de
septiembre cuando el nuevo o la nueva
primera ministra asumirán funciones